hola
es un placer para mí estar aquí el día
de hoy compartiendo les un poco sobre mi
tema de herramientas de cómo ser un
mejor estudiante la verdad es que el
tema puede sonar hoy en día un poco
cliché pero realmente las herramientas
para hacer un mejor estudiante no solo
se basan en tomar notas prestar atención
el día de hoy conectarte a clases o
simplemente estar en línea las
herramientas para hacer un mejor
estudiante se basan en muchas cosas
además de eso en mi experiencia como
estudiante tanto en secundaria como en
la universidad de kaiser me ha dado
cuenta de que la herramienta se basa en
en uno mismo y la primera herramienta
que me gustaría compartirle hoy que a mí
me ha funcionado y en la que me he
concentrado muchísimo en la organización
la organización para mí es primordial
para estudiantes no solamente la
organización de tener todos sus
cuadernos juntos de llevar un lápiz de
mantener todo ordenado dentro de tus
estudios no para mí la organización se
basa en métodos que puedes utilizar para
tus tareas métodos que utiliza en tu día
a día que no solamente se pueden
utilizar dentro del estudio pero también
en el ámbito laboral por experiencia
propia me ha dado cuenta de que la
organización es fundamental yo como
estudiante realmente intenté utilizar
muchísimas herramientas de estudio desde
la atech tecnología hasta lo más básico
lápiz y papel entre las herramientas que
podemos utilizar de organización de
tareas están el calendario de outlook el
calendario de google drive aplicaciones
para nuestros celulares
el papel y lápiz agenda cosas tan
simples que tenemos hoy en día con la
tecnología que pueden ser utilizadas en
nuestro día a día
realmente a mí no me han funcionado bien
las herramientas tecnológicas yo intenté
todo desde aplicaciones para mi teléfono
recordatorios alarmas utilizar el
calendario de outlook nunca me funcionó
y yo lo veía un poquito raro porque
valga la redundancia yo soy bastante
desorganizada soy bastante desordenada
en general y yo intentaba yo intentaba
organizarme dentro de lo que podría ser
verdad pero me di cuenta de que las
herramientas más básicas que era una
agenda y un lapicero verdaderamente me
funcionaban y es lo que ocupo hoy en día
todo lo que voy a hacer durante mi día
me ha ayudado a organizarme a dar un
paso adelante
en el ámbito estudiantil y la
organización no solamente te ayuda a
mantener tu día sino que te ayuda a
distribuir tu tiempo porque la
distribución del tiempo también es
fundamental para una estudiante no
solamente te puede pasar en una pareja
todo el día sino que tenés que
distribuir tus clases de la manera que
pueda sacarle provecho la segunda
herramienta
que mi experiencia me daba cuenta que no
muchas personas toman en cuenta el auto
cuido y cuando me doy cuenta de la falta
que muchos estudiantes tienen del
autocuidado me relaciono porque el auto
cuyo no solamente se basa en salir a
cortarte el pelo salir con tu amigo ir
al salón o salir a jugar no el auto cuyo
también se basa en la salud mental es
algo fundamental en estos tiempos de
pandemia porque como estudiantes
nosotros tenemos una presión dentro de
nosotros el hecho de salir bien en clase
es fundamental pero también el hecho de
cuidarnos a nosotros y mantener todo
bajo control también es algo
importantísimo
estudiantes ahorita en estos tiempos me
di cuenta de que estaba pasando por un
momento bastante como yo yo oscuro
porque yo tengo un trastorno de ansiedad
severo que no había descubierto y que
estaba teniendo un impacto sobre envía
estudios y yo no lo veía el impacto
dentro de mis notas pero vi el impacto
dentro de mis sentimientos el hecho de
que yo no quería hacer nada el hecho de
que no me quería levantar no quería ir a
clases no me quería ver con nadie me
hizo darme cuenta de que algo estaba mal
en mí y lo importante de darse cuenta de
que algo anormal es que puedes pedir
ayuda tienes la habilidad de pedir ayuda
y hacerles saber tanto a tus familiares
a tu amigo a tus profesores de que algo
anda mal entonces el auto cuido para
enviar ha sido una herramienta
importantísima para ser un mejor
estudiante porque realmente cuidarse a
uno mismo cuidar cómo te sentís es
importante dentro de tu estudio si no
quieres hacer nada si no quieres
levantarte no tenéis manera de motivar
te levantar y hacer algo no tenés manera
de entregar tus tareas no tenéis la
capacidad de decir ok hoy me voy a
levantar y voy a estudiar para tal y tal
clase entonces no es posible que
nosotros no nos cuidamos y es importante
porque muchos de nosotros tenemos placer
para cuidarnos
por ejemplo en kaiser tuve el agrado de
encontrarme con la psicóloga la doctora
rojas y ella fue fundamental para mi
desarrollo y el autocuidado de la salud
mental que tengo hoy en día una
herramienta que como estudiante en serio
deberíamos de considerar la tercera
herramienta que me gustaría compartirles
la noche de hoy que para mí ha sido
también importante es la disposición la
disposición como estudiante es algo muy
importante porque si estás dispuesto a
hacer algo poder seguir adelante si
estás dispuesto a ayudar a tus
compañeros también es importante porque
como estudiantes como persona la
disposición es lo que hace crecer o por
lo menos en mi caso la disposición es lo
que me ha hecho crecer como persona en
todos los ámbitos ámbitos generales
laborales estudiantiles como tutor
actualmente me ha dado cuenta de que
disponiendo mis servicios hacia una
persona le sacó provecho tanto para mis
estudios como para el estudio de los
demás y es increíble ver la capacidad
que tenemos nosotros tanto como personas
como tutores como estudiantes de poder
ayudar a otros y no solamente te hace
ser un mejor estudiante sino que te hace
ser una mejor persona porque es algo
reconfortante ver el hecho de que puedes
ayudar a alguien dentro de tus
capacidades capacidades como estudiante
ayudarles con clases ayudarles con sus
problemas etcétera entonces estas tres
herramientas para mí como estudiante en
secundaria y actualmente en la
universidad han sido sumamente
importantes porque no solamente me han
ayudado a desarrollarme como persona
sino como
estudiando y como una persona que hoy
soy siento que como estudiantes nosotros
crecemos cada día y crecer cada día es
algo importante porque el desarrollo
estudiantil pues es fundamental la
verdad de las cosas es de que las
herramientas estudiantes
[Música]
tomar notas en conectarte a clases y
andar sus cuadernos no las herramientas
son
importantes
la organización la disposición el habla
el dar ayuda el recibir ayuda recibir
ayuda en una situación que en la que no
te tiene que dar pena porque muchos
profesores durante secundaria y
actualmente en la universidad me han
dicho de que preguntar no es algo malo
preguntar algo importante porque te
ayuda a aclarar tus ideas aclarar tus
dudas y yo era una persona y actualmente
soy una persona bastante tímida
referente a las clases pero he
desarrollado en la habilidad de
preguntar y a veces soy bastante
intimidante en ese sentido porque
pregunto demasiado hasta estar clara no
me gusta salir de una clase y no tener
claras la idea o la organización de mi
idea entonces preguntamos preguntamos
sobre las clases preguntamos sobre lo
que tenemos es lo que tenemos duda
preguntar no está mal preguntarnos algo
no es algo malo para tus profesores es
más yo he visto por experiencia que los
profesores
se sienten orgullosos cuando preguntas
cuando tenés la valentía de preguntarles
de aclarar tus dudas porque ellos saben
de que una vez aclarando va a hacer algo
bien va a hacer algo positivo además de
que el hecho de preguntar te ayuda a tu
compañero a agarrar la valentía de
preguntar también entonces todas estas
herramientas se ven tan simples vemos
las cosas tan simples pero son
importantes porque si las cosas tan
simples como nuestros sentimientos como
lo que hacemos en nuestro día a día y
las herramientas que podemos utilizar
son los que nos ayudan crecer son los
que desarrolla nuestro bienestar nuestra
salud nuestra idea y es fundamental para
nosotros tener toda esta herramienta en
cuenta y yo como estudiante pues es un
agrado para mí venir y brindar toda esta
herramienta a ustedes porque si se lo
que se sienten no tenerla se lo que se
sienten no lograr identificar esta
herramienta y fallar por tal motivo
todos tenemos nuestro alto y bajo pero
si no logramos identificar cuáles son
las mejores herramientas para nosotros
si no logramos identificar cómo
organizarnos como auto cuidarnos o cómo
disponer y motivarnos sobre estas
herramientas
definitivamente que no vamos a poder
lograr nada es sumamente importante que
nosotros como estudiantes tengamos en
cuenta todo esto porque nos va a ayudar
a crecer tanto en el ámbito laboral como
en nuestro día a día muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah